[Music]
good morning guys it is Wednesday March
25th
it is officially my sixth day that I
have not left the house at all
besides like you know going around the
neighborhood but oh I'm bored I'm
starting to get cabin fever even though
there's a lot of things to do around the
house and we've been trying to keep busy
it's like oh man like there's only so
much you can do before you start getting
really bored I mean even watching the
office for the last two days even that's
getting boring so how have you guys been
holding up during this whole quarantine
stuff because I'd like some tips on what
you guys are doing I know there's a lot
of things I can also do like for example
I have always wanted to learn how to
play the piano and I actually have a
piano that can teach me how to play the
piano cuz you plug in the iPad and
there's like a little program so that's
something that's been on my to-do list
that I haven't gotten to so maybe I'll
do that
later today if I find time but update on
the whole IKEA bed situation they were
supposed to deliver four boxes for that
bed only two of them were delivered I
tried calling IKEA and it just
completely constantly disconnects me
from the line because they're saying
that they're receiving is like high call
volume or whatever and so I'm not able
to get through to them at all
I also emailed nothing I also Twitter
damn them nothing I also contacted the
delivery service that IKEA used to
deliver the bed frame they were like
there's nothing we can do we gave you
whatever the IKEA gave us so Isaac's
kind of stuck without a bed right now so
he's the most upset about it obviously
he says his bed frame so I don't blame
him yeah I've been trying to solve that
little issue but I guess like it's
understandable you know like during this
whole time in the world right now it's
like okay furniture is the least of
anyone's worries so I get it I'm not
tripping that hard about it but yeah I
don't know they've just kind of such
were Isaac because he really was looking
forward to having his bed we enjoyed our
new red couch last night though that was
really
a lot of family time during these days a
lot of little side projects I came
across this article about like what like
morally like what are some things you
can and can't do and stuff and obviously
you know going outside into the world
where you can possibly run into other
people that's a no-no I also looked into
like is it immoral to order things
online and then you know having people
deliver them like are you putting
yourself in danger you're putting the
delivery people in danger like what are
the moral ethics there and I came across
some stuff that some so some people
their opinions are no it's not a big
deal for you to order things there's job
security for the delivery people and the
stores that you're actually ordering
from because you're giving them business
so it's a good thing it's stimulating
the economy and people have jobs like
the delivery people and then there's
another side that's like don't order
things that you don't need because that
amount of effort could be placed into
more necessities like things that people
actually need in their homes and so like
the more people are ordering online like
the more necessary things get pushed
back which I also found out that that's
not true like for example with Amazon if
you order things online that are
necessities like that's gonna take
priority over anything else that's not
important yeah I've been kind of like
internal battling am i doing a bad thing
by ordering furniture and like trying to
complete this home or am i doing a good
thing
so and I decided that I am doing a good
thing job security stimulate stimulating
the economy the delivery people are
keeping themselves safe I like I
mentioned yesterday by leaving the
packages in the front of the house by
not actually stepping inside anyone's
home so for that reason I have still
been ordering things that we need for
the house and that's where I'm at with
that how do you guys feel about all that
and just this morning we got a couple
packages so I got a new cat scratcher
for the kitties and then the trays that
are supposed to be up here the TV trays
you guys see that I have a huge rat in
the house what is this oh it's a cat oh
and a boy I have a cat and a boy back
here that's how cute it did not know
you're back there I think
over here summon one to get him and then
I got stuck over there so good stuck I
was trying to flip and I got stuck but
then I got unstuck sounds coming this
way
mm-hmm not a turn oh I see I know how to
turn around right here just so funny
are you all so bored my boy yeah hey but
I'm super proud of you by the way you've
been so responsible with your homework I
read for an hour you read for a whole
hour
what time to wake up you woke up way
before me oh not that much before me
let's go he's enjoying all the love he's
purring really loudly by the way uh this
this little kitty boy he pooped on our
bed yesterday we were laying here all
nights or not all night but like you
know a good chunk of the night we were
laying right here and so we're right
next to the bed which you could just see
right there right and we had the door
open cuz we're like oh you know the cats
are chillin with us or like there's no
way he'll poop on her bed and we've
lived here for like three weeks now and
he's he hadn't pooped on her bed yet and
we were like oh man he pooped on the
floor and that was the first time like
it goes only been one time many boobs oh
wait now it's been twice well we were
here watching the office this cat
decided to poop on our bed and I'm like
are you kidding me
and I always have talks with him and I'm
always like why would you do this to us
so why why do you do this to us we give
you a nice home we have loved you and
taken care of you we feed you all the
time when we make sure kitty litter is
nice and clean and you disrespect us
like that by pooping on our bed The
Audacity look at a few dozen categories
we're gonna see daddy and then we bought
you a little a new cat scratcher thingy
but then in the middle of the night I
heard them scratching on this thing so
I'm like are you serious are you serious
right now
you cute kitty you could just do
anything and we'll forgive you because
we love you
will that feel
husbands doing hola bien gases huh bien
gases gases gay asset of gases no I look
at significa gases were that thumbnail
oh yeah we're gonna work see Syria muy
bien Trebek and oh the estoy trabajando
doing a shop trabajar work work toy
trabajando doodle oh my word no yo
quiero que tú digas to Tortuga sudhi
estoy trabajando we're bein a storage
travel oh I'm working
muy bien
Hey muy bien see Lacey stay oh yeah yo
suit habla espanol Tolia okay class
Hindi service nothing the video that
I've loved in espanol uh that that's the
word I should say no say no say no say
hey there's an oblivion besides que lo
mas que hablan espanol semester we are
not Panthers palabras por que nunca la
practica now ripped estoy pensando que
cuando vamos a la tarde este video we're
tener que tal see you guys Sara notching
up on your mouth
orderly well it's all right very nice
and exotic there just now exotic yes I
was an exotic woman wow you're super
exotic to look at you Asian band I mean
my little chinito man I came in such
- how it's easy for you to switch over
from English in Spanish but it's hard
like if I'm in English mode it's hard to
like what's the Chinese word for
everything I'm thinking about right now
it's a look of a bus at that man I said
okay so he said Monticello does but a
local no look so you're gonna know he
love me me language say exactly super
your tongue is not working no the
economy Lima Sekou Sundiata Spaniards
MSM especially math palabras million
element a I could Rico since I show that
is my human path or and they lay their
way you enjoy a condo to Manya yeah do
you not Rita tell me how your tongue
right now saying - yeah might have an
English tongue I can't speak my Chinese
my the Chinese tongue requires certain
muscles and I'm like I can't do it
anymore
yeah I was saying like the more i use my
tongue the more I get used to speaking
in Spanish and then the more Spanish
words come to my mind as I'm speaking so
it must be nice some more I speak
Chinese so less confidence I haven't
really because I think I used to be a
lot better with Chinese like I used to
watch more Chinese movies like living
with my parents are growing up like they
used to watch stuff and then like and
like I don't know you travel to Hong
Kong more frequently in back then I was
more in tune at that side of my life and
then after having moved out here which
is ironic cuz I'm moving out here and I
spent the last 10 years living in like
the most concentrated part of the US
with in terms of Chinese people hmm but
I don't we don't actually use the
Chinese I don't know that's weird I know
I don't know yeah so I've lost it and
the more I lose it
less confident I am when I do you I know
I totally forgot all the Chinese I was
learning cuz I really got discouraged
red yeah that's all I'm really yeah it
was just the colors mainly for some
reason long sick and homesick really
stick with me a lot
yes yes I'm saying or no hmm
I don't know that what tut tut
but I'm thinking nurse nurse from French
my name is nur yeah oh you know we have
all this time now we should be huh we
should be trying to learn something I
was just telling them upstairs that that
piano can teach me how to play and you
can also teach me and so can Isaac
should I really have no excuse to not
learn the piano
no we should pick up musical instrument
I have actually been doing ever since
moving here and I've been playing a lot
of piano these days I want to learn an
instrument
yeah so true I could totally take any of
that up but you know what I'd rather do
what right now what open those we got
some new packages I'm not even too sure
what that is over there but here's my
trace the new cat thingy so today is
Wednesday there's no jakey news prep day
today because tomorrow we're not filming
and and so yeah we wanna hire this in
terms of filming and it's been like a
lot of uncertainty when it comes to what
are we gonna do with jakey news luckily
we have a stockpile and because of the
stockpile like we've actually reduced
the amount of videos we upload every day
at one point I was five videos and then
went down a four and then it went down
to three and I think right now it is now
two videos a day we're uploading on
jakey news so today's a nice chill
Wednesday
I'm enjoy
now I like it when I think about it I'm
like all right so we started opening up
some boxes there's a TV trays as we
pulled them out it has been playing nice
background music the boy is building
stuff and I'm gonna be building the
stand for the TV trays and then next is
this cat thingy for the kitties Isaac
all those years of buy new LEGO sets
have trained you for this building week
how do you feel
do you like building stuff yeah it's
pretty fun yeah I've gotten used to it
does it remind you of the Legos a little
bit cuz you just follow the instructions
piece by piece right yeah personally the
IKEA saw how you've been helping me
build a lot of stuff yeah it does remind
me of the good old days with the Legos
yeah yeah this is grown-up Legos all
right so look from the new cat pad or
what is this cat tree I put the pads
here to kind of get the kitty scent from
the old one before we get rid of it
look those already really curious he's
like what is this I want to play with
that I want to play with the new toy
though do you approve because once you
approve your sister will approve she
does anything you say how cute he likes
it what do you think dude who do you
think was your sister Maya oh she likes
hiding under there Maya go check out the
new toy girl
come on little girl look your brother is
enjoying it she's like me how cute he
really likes it my ass it almost with
this framing it almost looked like zou
was really tiny she was like staring
right at him I love it when she tucks
her little paws under her chest it's so
cute Mya go play with them you toy
what's going on the boy you mean help
doing hold it you sure
Hey look at you you want zero help he
has been building this all on his own by
the way yeah I built this little cat
tree since those now enjoying we like it
my boy and I finished building this
thing what it came all dirty like this
not cool yeah I built the stand for this
eventually we're gonna have an armed war
here to put towels and extra stuff here
obviously this chair is gonna be moved
to Isaac's room we left it out here
because we thought we were gonna be
building his bed but Santa's not coming
in for who knows how long we can move
this back into his room there we go just
picture a desk here
picture this there is a desk there is
the chair those two boxes it's gonna be
a little dresser bench thing that I
talked about before and then once he
actually gets his frickin debt bed frame
huh I'm out of breath see everything's
coming along now we're just gonna put
stuff up on the walls I was thinking
about doing a wallpaper on this wall too
that would be kind of cool but who knows
who knows what I come up with what I
will be coming up with I'm enjoying your
music
yeah what are you playing when a tango
song that I heard in the I was randomly
looking up YouTube songs on YouTube
videos and no I went to a rabbit hole of
people playing piano and like random
songs are playing mm-hmm and there's
this tango song called nada no yeah and
it's like a very beautiful tune and I
was like I kind of tracked that song
down and I found some like three sheet
music like a preview that action bunch
keeping the oh my god it's screen capped
it and like two pieces look there's the
spring cap one in screen just buying it
it is okay I'm gonna learn you know oh
my gosh I like learning the basic
version and then I'm gonna add my own
roll I'm not and so I don't really care
to learn exactly what's written on the
sheet so through spice it up myself
yeah your mustache is coming in nicely
you know I give it it's like really
thick it was Isaac's idea yeah it's too
growing out he was like you should throw
it out quarantine style
once we've been in quarantine for a long
time you've been shaving this you
haven't shaving the bottom part to be
honest I'm not a fan of facial hair but
you rocket it's fine really I got the
face to rock a mustache mmm sure yeah
yeah it's growing up always didn't like
the most - it's all just kind of kind of
like mustaches are lame hmm Isaac said
it's a good idea oh my gosh that's gonna
be good
what do you think Isaac
[Music]
possibly grow wait what are you gonna
grow a mustache easy oh yeah I see a
peach fuzz if you actually grow thick
hair though are you gonna grow it out
nope
really why not you don't wanna mess - I
don't want a mess - I want a massage who
do you call that screwdriver screwy
screwy
where did we get the screwdriver from
right there yeah this screwy came with
the nest thermostat and it's been
Isaac's favorite companion these past
couple of days we've been building stuff
and it's pretty cool watch do you want
to show them the other side of the head
it turns into a flat head that's pretty
cool a little screwy that's your best
companion through these building days
huh Wow look who we got here nice and
comfy huh how you enjoying the new couch
/ almost bed it's practically a bed you
like it yeah yeah it's pretty comfy I
was gonna update the vlog and show them
what we did
we built a whole bunch of stuff today
mm-hmm you want to first show them the
the white cabinet you were working on oh
yeah look at what I did to it enter the
master bedroom now the master bathroom
and now the master toilet room you built
that all on your own my boy out of you
and then I got some like toilet paper
some of my stuff seven health care what
is it what hair feminine care that's the
word feminine care products feminine
feminine venom and cinnamon you know
wasn't roseola take the marble and I'm
finna know which movie that
Avengers that's it and then you and I
built this together so this is Isaac's
new dresser slash bench he is able to
sit on it if you would like like so
sleep yep
I mean that's definitely gonna be a lot
less comfortable in this now how old
BigTable nice to have in the old house
big table which one we still have them
in the garage
oh the coffee tables and coffee tables
yeah I would like sometimes when I
didn't have glasses or when they broke
them and did I have my contacts or I
didn't wear them yeah actually I think I
was too lazy to get my glass on the
coffee table and then I was so
comfortable really without a pillow or
anything no yeah without a fella so I
added a pillow and a blanket nice Oh see
like the hardness you like how like hard
and like flat it is it's funny because
it's only things things that are built
or like something that's leveled
couldn't make sleep on the floor it's
uncomfortable Oh interesting so you like
it a more elevated flat surface a flat
hard surface this is comfortable I could
see you enjoying that look at that you
look really really comfortable let's
just grab your pillow and then boom my
boy and then here grab the blanket there
we go
this could be your bed for the night oh
no I'm sorry baby I'll do it for you
I'll do it is it comfy though it's
pretty comfy you're just like me oh my
goodness you know when I was your age I
moved into my my walk-in closet you
didn't yes and my closet was a lot
smaller than the closet that we have
here it was only as big as a twin size
mattress that's how how big my walk-in
closet was and I ended up moving my
mattress in the closet and I think I
stayed in there for like a couple months
I just loved how tiny it was but my mom
told me that I couldn't sleep with the
clothes because she was scared that was
in the suffocate in there oh your window
no it's a closet oh yeah I guess my
closet has a window but no usually
closets don't have windows did it have
like one of those doors where does it
have a underneath like like scrapes the
floor oh yeah like where I could
actually suffocate no I wasn't it was a
regular door my mom was just being
really extra cautious he's oh so was
visiting your new piece of furniture and
then I got this other crazier idea where
I thought the you know in Harry Potter
how he his room is under the stairs
yeah the cupboard under the stairs yeah
so during that same house when I moved
into my walk-in closet I ended up moving
into the cupboard space
but it was way too small to fit my
actual mattress so I was actually
sleeping on the floor and also it was so
small that I couldn't even fit my entire
body like I would end up sleeping like
this like in a little ball and for some
reason I just loved it and I was like
yes I can this room get any tinier I was
I was a weird kid so I just love the
fact that you are just like your mother
it's really cute but then I I remember I
sleep in that box remember that long big
box we sat oh yeah what did we order for
that book we used to have this really
really long box I don't remember what we
ordered but we ordered something and I
was like this really it was a similar
sized box as this actually and you put a
bunch of blankets in there and pillows
you slept in there telling them many
times did you sleep in there is a week I
forgot who it was but what do you when
are you one of you parent
what do you parents mean what do you
guys told me that if you sleep in a
position where you can stretch your legs
stretch your legs you can't get any
taller
scare me so I stopped sleeping the
bottom I remember one time
I remember one time I was a realize yeah
and then I'm like screw this and I just
start punching my feet you did so my
feet could stick out but the whole thing
came out oh I think I remember that and
then he came in he opens the door like
you're okay oh yeah and then I slapped
on my I slept on my bed I think you
slept whoo oh my baby boy you're so cute
I do remember telling you that legit
though I I don't know you know how they
have in Japan those no do you remember
we saw like square shaped watermelon in
Japan so what's all that I'm person yeah
I remember I pointed out to you forgot
though the first time we went to Japan
not the second time I remember okay well
maybe because you're too little you're
like seven but how they are able to make
it into a square is because when the
watermelons really small they put it in
like a little like a case kind of thing
to make it like so as it's growing it's
gonna be that shape so by you staying in
a box like just like this like how I was
staying in that room under the stairs
exactly the same way like a I don't know
I feel like you won't grow right like
you won't grow properly so that I think
that that was my logic and reasoning
behind that are you gonna really fall
asleep on top of the dresser m-maybe
alright then good night
[Music]